il y avait aussi des manifestants plutôt
virulent une journaliste de rtl rabique
en a malheureusement fait les frais elle
s'appelle dalian à marie elle couvrait
donc le procès de benyamin nétanyahou
elle se trouvait précisément à côté de
militants de l'ultra droite israélienne
elle a été prise à partie
impossible pour elle d'effectuer dans de
bonnes conditions son travail on écoute
tout de suite les policiers israéliens
nous ont demandé de nous tenir derrière
une clôture métallique à côté de
militants de l'ultra droite israélienne
ils ne nous ont pas laissés bouger de
cet endroit nous demande répétée à la
police de nous laisser nous déplacer
vers un autre endroit ont toutes essuyé
un refus les militant d'ultra droite
lorsqu'ils nous ont entendu parler en
arabe alors que je tentais d'enregistrer
le son pour un reportage sur le procès
netanyahu ont commencé à nous provoquer
ils m'ont poussé plusieurs fois et l'un
d'entre eux a levé la main pour essayer
de me frapper
et ce malgré le fait que je lui avais
déjà demandé de reculer pour me laisser
travailler et nous éviter d'être infecté
par le coronavirus ou autre chose il a
encore essayé de m'attaquer devant la
police israélienne notre opérateur et
moi nous sommes appuyés sur la clôture
métallique pour tenter de partir car il
avait également été attaquée par les
colons israéliens se trouvant derrière
lui c'est un manque de respect évident
pour la liberté de la presse et la
liberté d'expression